rising from the deep a majestic tiger
shark drawn in by fish scraps he's right
at the top of the food chain and he may
hold clues to the health of the ocean
but to study him closely
these Bermudan scientists need to reel
him in the hook is harmless
once restrained the ocean tech team
takes a biopsy to be checked later for
toxic chemicals from plastics and other
pollution animals are digesting the
animals that they have eaten
they are also ingesting the toxins the
plastics and all the man-made pollutants
that we are putting into the ocean so it
works its way up the food chain into the
Sharks so typically sharks have higher
levels because they're a large predator
this is an incredible animal very
muscular rub your hand one way smooth go
the other and it is just like sandpaper
to understand the threat to sharks you
need to go back to where the problem
starts just just on the answer in the
shadow there
that's all plastic this is all little
bits of plastic you can see it this is
micro plastic tiny fragments of toys
bottles and other bags broken apart by
the Sun and the waves now brought in by
the tide 21st century flotsam and the
fish mistake it for food in a bucket
like this you've got the organic things
that you would expect to see they're
like the leaves and the sticks you know
and out on the wat in the ocean you'd
see the small fish and the little
jellyfish and things like that that the
wildlife there is feeding on all our
stuff is blue white purple and what we
see here is blue whites purples all the
plastics that have broken down so this
is the nightmare here when the plastic
gets to the thighs because how do you
get rid of that more than five trillion
pieces of plastic are estimated to be
floating in the world sees just a
fraction washes ashore the material
never rocks or disappears by 2050 its
predicted the plastic in the ocean will
weigh more than all the fish
with its warm seas and white sands but
muta is something of a paradise but it
is a paradise that being trashed he lies
on the edge of the Atlantic Garbage
Patch a huge swirling mass of plastic
that's been brought together by the
ocean currents and this Beach only looks
this good because it's regularly cleaned
some of it comes from a long way away
this is an octopus pot from West Africa
4,000 miles across the ocean this a tube
that appears to have come from Turkey
man's mess washed here by the ocean
currents the plastics attract other
toxic chemicals washed into the ocean
such as flame retardants and pesticides
and they too could make it into the food
chain you can see very clearly that this
fish has been chewing on this particular
plastic maybe more than one fish who
knows how long it's been out there
scientists have been monitoring the
pollution and fear it could pose a
threat to human health well the more we
look for where plastic is and the
former's in big and small microscopic
stuff that you can't see the stronger
its integrated into food webs and
therefore it's the only place that can
go when is in the food web is up to the
top and worth the sitting at the top so
we have the most to lose here by losing
you know access to these food resources
scientists don't yet know whether sharks
are harmed by the chemicals and their
bodies but they shouldn't be there and
that as a warning for us all Thomas
Moore Sky News Bermuda